hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast sampling for cannabis
testing presented by Sean Kastner he's
senior scientist at Neptune and company
I am Judy O'Rourke of lab Rhodes and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots lab roots is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before I begin I would like
to remind everyone this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop down box that
appears on the screen we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the promotional
board at the bottom center of your
screen or use the ask a question box to
let us know that you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming Sean
Kastner I will now turn the presentation
over to him well welcome everyone today
I'll be talking about cannabis sampling
the importance of stem and the portals
of sampling is the rule assembly within
the community and the importance of
sampling and it's a pertains to testing
so today what we're going to go through
we're going to go ahead and start with
the role of sampling in within the
marijuana industry when the ethics of
sampling are the standard operating
procedures we're going to go do a quick
review what those are they're going to
look at sampling strategies for flour
and concentrates and edibles and then
talk about laboratory coordination so
why are we example exactly because we're
testing is required look at those
reasons
we're testing we're as far as military
compliance product safety and
manufacturing information so the
regulatory testing goals are we're
looking for product testing for product
safety for Microbiology constituents
whether those be Seminole or the BT coli
doctor or Listeria organism per se you
know are different toxins for mycotoxins
as far as residual solvents for
concentrates and then the different
pesticides that are out there but for
most of states they're all different so
that less throughout the states so that
there's a large variety number of them
to worry about and the different
analyses as well as metals analyses the
other reason where the regulatory goals
for testing are to understand and make
sure that we have accurate labeling or
dosage for them from different medical
American medical marijuana the
regulatory concentration limits for
adult use and then just for overall
product safety concerns but the goal for
the community for them for is that your
cultivator manufacturer goals are for
product safety doing meet regulatory
compliance within for the prompt for
narcotics and we care about a customer
so want to make sure we're putting out a
good quality product that is safe for
people to consume and then there's
product liability this is something we
don't talk about very often just because
we have products therefore we do have
product liability and that's something
that I say interesting but rulers are
going to be worrying about them and
talking about as we move forward you
also want to make sure they're meeting
regulatory requirements for labeling
making sure we have the right
information on their smartphones egos
and moving forward we've got once again
we care about I care about our customers
we want to provide think our customers
the post factor information as far as
what potency levels are animals are we
also want to know for marketing purposes
we want to know what the books on our
cabinet can what those are we want to go
with the cleanliness or a product art
and that does feed into market and we'll
just put it out there and beyond
instability and then for product
manufacturing we need to know what the
potency levels are so when we start them
using concentrates to manufacture other
products that don't we take that into
account and so it's a polity control
check for that and that's what ensure
there is any microt
chromium contamination of their or
that's brought debate or mediate those
microbial contamination so no sampling
really is what is a bit how does it work
within within the realm of the community
basically you are right here you're
right in between cultivation of growing
and extracting and then moving samples
off to the laboratory it fits into the
cycle of applied for a particular
product whether you start at the
laboratory world and they go from
testing which goes into the state of
regulatory databases like metric and
then goes onto product labels and so the
whole product process moves around in
this circle that we've demonstrated so I
is simply important simple represents
the harvest batch of your production
batch that are about to be sold
whether it be flowers or concentrates or
emptyness products all the information
that the laboratory provides us from the
little quarry to do is based on the
samples that you take so all that data
represents what that product is and we
want to make sure is that Dean is as
accurate as possible but it's also used
for manufacturing edibles and on animals
so that is why everything is important
all the information about how he is a
sample who is using the simple how its
manufactured use of an efficient process
all comes from the testing which is
based on those samples in your
confirmation or any bias to your
sampling technique or for limited
imagination will impact the data
generated by the laboratory so any type
of adulteration putting your sample in a
microwave or cutting down the microbial
contaminants all are going to impact the
testing and there is no amount of
analytical testing that can fix an
appropriate bad someone it's just if not
you're just able to come to recover from
that so when you example several
probably the best place to sample is at
the very end of the process just before
your final product is goes off into
public for sale
so for spoiler and sampling just after
that it's after the drying process but
before the final packaging and for
edibles and non animals what happens is
and for concentrates it's whatever your
the final form is that before goes off
to to the customer as well so typically
this had done to further perform or
homogeneity testing so that the products
that are offered such as brownies and
cookies and things can be tested for
homogeneity and making sure that the
sample the kinetically concentration is
evenly distributed throughout that
particular sample concentrates refiner
keeps and manufacturing as a final
product it depending did that depends on
when the ste requirements are as well as
the business requirements and then
weren't the form in which everything is
being used for artists to concentrate
cups of liquid concentrates as far as
teachers go they're more solid
concentrates such as shadow waxes and
the lash so those are the things that we
were again for something for non edibles
it's after the product is in its final
form so we had lotions and different on
other products like that that we look at
as far as being in its final part before
we move it out again done to ensure that
there's homogeneity within the product
dr. menville interim are under this are
spread evenly through the product or for
dosing purposes so have to understand
that the sampling computes the greatest
amount of error to the testing program
or sampling that is inconsistent leads
to laboratory results that are
inconsistent on that you can also leak
to cross contamination if we get sake
and if you don't imagine is a sample as
well then we don't have good
understanding of what's going on with
the new product so therefore you might
feel your sample there as well all of
these resources there that gets
propagated by the laboratory because
what they do is they take your sample
your that you've collected and then some
simple on them and some simple those
into for their analysis whether it
compromising with me for microbiology
purposes or whether pesticides or metals
whatever the testing is that you're
having done at the time so let's talk
about sampling ethics because this is
where we've seen some more important
things going on within the industry so
what is that what does it mean to be
ethical leaven ethical means pertaining
to or dealing with the principles of
morality pertaining to what is right and
what is wrong in conduct this means
conducting yourself in a manner that is
honest transparent had appropriate to
the task so basically what that means to
the individual doing the sampling when
they work for sampling company or your
work for facility or you working for
laboratory was doing the same way this
is following the real procedures that
you were trained to following your SOP
your standard operating procedures
before in the tasks that are supported
to your company goals or to the goals of
the laboratory which has been getting
the best most representative data for
the product center samplers and make
sure that those products are truly
representative of the product that the
company has produced or that your
compass for instance you're actually
doing the rewards yourselves but yeah it
certainly is the most critical point to
the testing process it's at the very
beginning of a testing process so
samplers are responsible for collecting
representative samples ensuring that
there's mental desperation ensuring that
sex and that samples are collected with
the aseptic technique or an aseptic
manner samples that are collected
representing what the product is being
sold in public
so whatever in the assembly collection
processes and what the testing process
is that is what that information is
moving forward so again any errors or
biases and sampling process ends up in
the data which ends up on the label and
so we want to avoid unethical sampling
not taking samples that are commercially
advocate just to sampling the best of
about or charity thinking simples don't
it don't treat the samples are being
sent to laboratory example of microwave
in microbiology samples and not
following some keys that are written
taking shortcuts that's what these are
written to incorporate all the steps
that appropriate and taking shortcuts
around them can be friendly to an elite
decontamination
until they - all sorts of things
falsifying data
and you said it was certain exempt
amount and then eventually said they get
something else all that information is
typically tracked through there so what
happens like if you were to head for
sampling but what happens when if the
source a negative consequences go well
we've seen in energy recalls recalls a
product because of microbe local
microbial contamination or pesticide
contamination we've seen this from the
commercial end of things we misrepresent
your product could be potentially
harmful and causing public health
concerns or issues but does microbial
contamination you can have the wrong
dosage you mean the dosage may be too
weak for medical marijuana previous in
chair and which may not give those folks
that needed enough pain relief hunger
stimulation a seizure dissipation that
they renamed and then as far as you can
immunocompromised spoke people with
using medical marijuana then because
there's an ultimate infection because
there are immunocompromised the other
thing is is to give you inconsistent
results inconsistent products which then
it leads to the beginning in consistent
usage having a wrong result or an
unexpected result
so that would comes back to your
reputation under company who you are as
a company and that's not something that
we want or risk so what is doing the
right things do we do have a little data
that's meaningful to your facility to
your company to your grow house to your
competition to the manufacturing process
and be able to use that data from
entrepot acrylic labels are really
sincere product not so clear
manufacturing purposes them for your own
growing purposes and helps you
understand what's going on with those
facilities on a few accuracy on your
labels is consistent product for batch
to batch it makes it predictable so your
customers know that they can come to
your company get the same product again
may be there again it's just like
McDonald's or just like Starbucks
everybody goes to Starbucks or
McDonald's because the same you get the
same product regardless of what city
you're in but regardless of what story
around a big bad something
lattes a lot today's a lot taking
strippers so that's what you want you
want to be able to make sure that the
customers know what they're getting and
they're like meaning of quality product
and that just improves the quality of
your overall company as well for those
of you doing on whatever something heads
so let's talk about those remember the
SOP is a standard operating procedure
well so what is innocent beef recipes is
a procedure that lists all the steps
necessary to complete a task
so in this task we're talking about
sampling what are all the steps it takes
you take into account to take a sample
from a flower or concentrates you
provide within the within the SOP enough
detail then anybody who has a reasonable
background within your company
laboratory can pick up the SOP and
complete the task without without with
minimal training these are living
documents and they will change and
improve as you use them and they should
be seen as looking documents SOPs are
never perfect and they're never always
complete it's kind of like doing the
laundry it's never quite done so why do
you need one
Medina SOP because you're doing the same
task over and over and over again and
they said that task is very quality
driven tasks like sampling you want to
make sure that when you're sampling that
you're doing things in consistent
reliable and in a biased manner so
having an SOP that outlines every single
step it takes to do sampling within
those within those same
wings too many consistent make it
reliable confusing will then allow you
to have the sampling that you need to
improve the quality assembly and make it
predictable for you as well
all this improves the quality of sembly
did you have produced that from the
samples as representative and the
thought of product being manufactured
the information will be presented by
your company is that accurate and
improved for better decision-making
further for your customers and the end
users and the data can indicate on the
value of the worth of your product as
well excuse me
what is the basic structure of the lips
of people what does it need to have in
it so all the SOPs have a very similar
structure whether they're environmental
laboratory SOPs or wheat or SOPs or the
sampling as a painter talking about
that's their purpose why are you writing
this okay
let's have terms and acronyms and
definitions so everybody understands
what the SOP is about and the terms
within it you have equipment and
supplies what you need to know the
controls in frequency how frequently are
in are you sampling what are the
requirements for people to sample what
are the sample amounts being collected
what day did you collect with the
samples the procedure how many samples
you're actually collecting what do you
what are the pre and post sampling
things you need to do leave a clean area
you need to make sure your equipment is
clean when you're done sampling clean
the area we should clean your equipment
um how do you simple are you simple what
container is you putting things into how
do you transport samples from your
facility to the laboratory what is a
hundred or the containers you know how
are you samples stored so they get to
the laboratory with minimal impact and
then one of the quality records and what
are the safety concerns as well one of
things you've seen as far as grooming in
the industry as well this is a safety
when we say the safety is first always
be aware when well as what's going on
what you're doing and where appropriate
safety suit apparel PPE personal
protective equipment sunblock our safety
glasses gloves lab coat those things
those are necessary of any additional
equipment your facility may require
hairnet cloth shoe covers etc that
you're working in foods and creating
edibles
it's a little do the things you need to
make sure that you're wearing at all
times let's talk about some sample
collection they're actually collecting
the sample there are different ways of
doing things and we want to go through
and talk about some different strategies
of looking at samples and collecting
them in an appropriate manner so how
many samples do I think and how much of
the samples do I collect make questions
and those vary between depending on what
state you're in
and what laboratories are working with
different states will tell you to
collect different samples depending on
your batch size different samples will
how much sample to take will vary upon
the laboratories are using or and/or the
state many states are coming out with
minimum sample sizes Colorado just came
out with the issue down to a a whole new
minimum sample size for microbiology or
get words to be ready to so whether
they're increasing that simplified so
the minimum not a sample that we were
encouraged completely to do and send me
of the laboratories who is one is two
and three analyses worth of sample that
way the laboratory has enough sample as
something goes wrong in the laboratory
or you need to retest they've got the
sample there that they can move forward
with though there are states like
Maryland who was the one who a lot of
the facilities to hold a sample
collected at the same time back to
facility but that's there's other room
kind of the outlier that the moment
sighs my product let's talk about
chronic per minute so a product may be
flour may be settled differently than
them bodies which will be simple
differently than shattered because of
the sample size and the batch sizes that
are there and you should always check
the regulatory agency or the regulations
to verify the form there are a number of
samples this seems to be changing with
every state with every rule change just
as we're not quite there as far as
tenderizing things go and as we're
moving to having standardized methods as
you can standardized processes will see
this starting to calm down and get more
standardized ways of knowing how much
sample to take knowing what is a
appropriate number of samples we want
make sure everything is statistically
valid and representatives complete
representative of what's going on is
with your samples as well or with your
badge size so let's talk strategies the
most important strategy or the most
important thing to have and for is
simply goes as aseptic technique which
is a specific set of practices or
procedures so that you minimize the
national pathogens or
cross-contamination when you're
collecting samples so it's taking the
time wearing gloves the proper equipment
and using the cleaning equipment to take
samples so how do you perform the
technique when you where's they're all
or sanitize gloves you use clean rinsed
and alcohol rinsed forceps cleans gel
sanitized containers to collect samples
into the room at PAX that which people
like to use a lot of them make sure that
those are clean and sanitized relax make
sure they're they're coming out of the
box clean and not been used before
change your gloves and clean equipment
between sampling events are between
sampling batches when you're
homogenizing samples if it's you're
allowed to do that to make sure you
rinse wash and rinse and an alcohol
rinse all your equipment make sure you
that everything is clean as possible
I'll just make sure you when you're
hollering see make sure you use enough
to remove all the oils or the pesticide
residues that may collect wills and
pesticides like to think to go to stick
together they extract in the very same
manner and this is introduced for
microbiology simple so these rules
reduce all forms like
cross-contamination whether it be
chemical odor or microbiological or or
any type of contamination so you wanna
make sure you have cleared a subject
aching so what are some examples
equipment list so you want to review
your equipment list before you begin
make sure you've got everything in
amounts so developer check to us for
that equipment that you need or isn't
sure they've got enough inventory
available to freezer assembling a bit of
clothes in a custody labels security
tape sample container ziplock bags and
make sure that everything is setup room
tool so the sampling event itself
doesn't take as much time this will make
sure that you're more efficient and then
you know spending your time sampling you
can spend your time doing some other
things that you're completely I want you
to do how make sure your missus scale is
and balances is calibrated by the state
whereas it as a current certificate
available
that was a requirements button from UM
from all the states all these things
over and then store your sampling
supplies separately and in a different
location so that they're always kept
segregated and clean and separate for
the what's going on within the facility
so let's take a look at some is giving
samples
so the example in the top examples on
the right and left a good technique
they're very very careful they're not
touching the sample with their hands
they're get you with the forceps and
they're making sure that samples are
putting it to the appropriate containers
won't be a back it's a backpack or glass
file I think I'm much going on and then
on the bottom pretty much shoes which
you should not be doing so that's and
although that's a picture of somebody
doing a trim it's the same thing it's
Jimmy's team as far as simple as also
not something you want me to with your
bare hands that's what you want so let's
talk about something strategies for
flour so when you're looking at sampling
in beds the power stored in in several
different ways can be sorted bins and
turkey bags how can we sort them drying
racks and then driving drawers and what
you want to be able to is we come in to
take samples out of these containers you
want to be on through the sample across
the containers and then not only from
the top but through throughout the
container from top to bottom and sample
the top portion the middle portion at
the bottom portion of each container as
well as going from the tank container
across ways so you can see the three
arrows moving down through the container
you want to be able to simple on either
end and make sure you're sampling within
the middle as well from them looks like
sampling at the top of the bag so you
want to make sure you're taking samples
across or within within the bed itself
that gives you the best representation
of what's going on within the bed not
just from grabbing guys from the top
same thing with sampling turkey bags for
example turkey bags in the same manner
want to be able to sample within the
back not only across the top from side
to side but also pump up and down
through so the top middle portion the
bottom portions as well so you wanna
make sure you do sample throughout those
all of those ways of looking at things
that gives you the best way of seeing
what's going on throughout the entire
bag
not just at the top they may be going on
within the bag itself that you've been
on see or know about so maybe microbial
growth to be mold competing females and
he's going there to be pro a lot of
other things which will encourage its
amply dragged as well again protests
accepted from a profound potency you
wouldn't want to follow a similar track
we'll talk about potency in a second so
you want to be able to sample plants at
each of those different locations you
know at the ends of the other drying
rack and within the middle as well then
where is only when we talk about potency
being a little bit different response
you want you're looking trying to look
at more of about an average number
what's going on throughout the around
the harvest so you may want to be you
want to be able to sample across the
plants as well now the user comes down
to I don't understand what's going on as
as far as for focusing it's not to get
the highest level over the highest
number for marketing purposes and not
only second best buds for that but to
understand what's going on throughout
the her entire harvest bench not the
most marketable desirable data perhaps
for marketing purposes but the most
accurate data for your customer and I
give you the best data that you wanna
move forward and that's what you're
selling to the public now that being
said is there are facilities in brewing
designs that that have used Google
selectively kick buttons and use them
for their product to be sold and the
rest by meeting sent off for attraction
purposes in that case you have to take a
look at what your operation is and how
you're doing things and make sure you're
sampling appropriately which you only
use in the top buds for that to purpose
then that spring then just sample those
440hz loans but if using the other team
the other buds for extraction then you
need to take a separate process so you
need to be able to document them yeah
and there are some piece as well so that
everybody knows what's going on and why
and that way when you do get inspected
you can and you can help explain here's
however here's how we sample and this is
why we're doing it because it did some
more business practices yeah I want a
simple at the plant level you want to do
similar you across you want to test
across the
as well but you also want to cross
sample across the plant if using using
all the pods form for purposes that way
and that way you look at your sampling
across the top in the middle on the
bottom of the plot and we don't do that
because we know that Kurt can add words
and turkeys vary with the plant location
as well at the top of the plant which is
at the bottom of screen we just need to
know that buds are Canada boys are at
the higher concentrations and you should
move upwards little screening in the
photograph that those can either place
entertain the lesson as you move up
toward your bottom of the plant trying
to Rack some drawers there are different
types that needs to be found in all
different facilities never getting up
going to as different ways of stairs I'm
storing things whatever works for them
is great and their system is built to
run them so we want to sample them in
the same manner that we simple to the
top of the bags why because they burn a
good randomize as part of the process
and trimming at night so let's talk a
little bit take a little bit closer look
so I want to be able to do is look at
the drawers and sample through the
drawers from top to bottom and then
within the doors sample around different
locations than that just ensured that
the sample is collected represent what's
going on not only with the entire rack
but within the drawer itself okay
concentrates concentrates are unique it
seems like to me no more types of
concentrates that we do with than
anything else so there are many
different types of constructs as we all
know the shadows of Keith there's black
scissors the last butters there's
liquids
there's oils and tinctures and other
extracts so this whole section will do
first section we can talk about just the
solid types of concentrates so as we're
looking at these we want to be able to
take representa samples around a part of
the content of the concentrate itself so
we'll use look at chatter an example we
want to be able to make sure we take
from different location
perhaps different stiffnesses I've seen
different papers talk about the four
especially for for shatter and some of
the other extracted solvent extraction
concentrates that the amount of residual
Sullivans may vary the thickness I've
seen anything definitive in that but
I've seen some papers written in that
Menem so you want to be able to take
take we would suggest you take a
cross-section of you know thin thick of
medium areas as far as the sample goes
it takes a little more time but it's
going to be much more representative of
which I've actually got going in there
and then the other part of the audit it
is is that the amount that you're taking
is going to be much less as far as
because you don't have as much simple
they're talking about a hundred grams
maybe 200 grams or so for most of the
shutters that are created for some of
the more thicker discus samples of we're
talking about a minute you're looking at
probably 700 you know less than a
kilogram specialist for a while so from
Wilson futures recommend this kind of
the supposed procedure using a pipette a
syringe stream over the sample amount to
be collected into a amber glass
autosampler vial or some other type of
file then those take a loquats at
different depths of the oil or given
tips of extract make sure you're
sampling you know representative taranta
job that can throw out the extract and
may be different locations perhaps as
well so to top in the middle of a third
of the container if you had that much
room to be able to do that would and
then this ham sample should be
homogenized before sending yourself
laboratory that way the you're getting a
much an assemble that that should
represent what's going on with it with
the oil because we really haven't seen a
whole lot of data yet talking about on
the canadian any products within that
and that's kind of one of funding the
other projects so finished edibles and
products food product any product is
typically when we're looking at edibles
we look at a couple of different things
that everything is finished ready for
distribution everything is set up to go
for being sold to the public that
different states require different
amounts to be simple the number of
samples that need to be taken there be
sampled overall when the per simples
overall meet across a batch whether
homogeneity testing is required within
the batch and within the product itself
and the types of analyst report we're
seeing more and more food related
requirements being headed to edible
products they're receiving seeing more
of as food with marijuana being added to
them or cannabis products and the oils
added to them as opposed to just be in
packaged products so we're seeing a lot
of the food industry requirements I'll
be added to the contestant requirements
as well well number Tory that we work
with actually is is working with
manufacturers who and the first thing
they do is test their based product
prior to adding any type of known of
oils or concentrates to it and so we
want to be able to say is how do you do
those honey handle is looking at it well
if you're required to take 10% of your
samples then you would go ahead and say
great there would be in every tenth
sample that you would take an example
here if you have a bad first batch of
300 on individually packaged cookies and
your minimum sample about is 29 you take
the total number of samples that you
have divided by the number of samples
that you're required to take and then
okay which would be in this case around
just over 10
but then in route to the nearest whole
number in this case 10 and then take
every 10 simple take you know where we
can simple until you can't capture 29
samples and that's how would you do that
in a randomized fashion and they can be
the best solution as far as
statistically representation of what's
going on best practice is to split
production batch into thirds I'm
randomly sample for each production and
imagine creating that is a noise sample
you're able to do that mr. Wyman came up
for the first approach as well the
sample collection then must be randomly
for the entire first batch up from them
try to match the samples reached into
that batch and you're still running
you're creating samples you start again
at their same process transportation to
the laboratory since most of most states
have any interstate transportation
they're all the confrontation till the
laboratory for samples happens with a
fairly short time frame one of the
things you want to ensure when you're
transporting samples is that nothing
affects the samples within during that
time so the time that they're sampled
the time that they actually reach the
laboratory nothing happens to the sample
that changes the sample so for example
if it's a hot summer day and then you
might want to have to worry about heat
effects cars make great incubators for
microbes and you don't want any
microbial contamination growing in the
samples being transported that isn't
actually going that isn't wasn't there
in the beginning at your facility didn't
cross contaminate or other symbols you
want that you want those your samples to
be exposed to others during that time
frame mother so how you package you know
you send things to them the amount of
time it takes to transport things and
how do you maintain your sample
integrity who's employed to the end
process you know what I didn't happen
are there no simple she just worked so
hard to try to invert diligently but
even make sure that those things that
are packaged appropriately
perhaps in a color I'm sure even sure
that there's there a kept cold oh so
you've got a microbial growth so it
means maintains a growth of what it was
when you packaged it and keep everything
else pot and make sure that nothing else
happens to the samples so those are
things to take into account when we talk
about transporting symbols to the
laboratory someone's received their
weight and measure to make sure they're
compliant then they're then subdivided
into different so
for analysis and you know what they're
being analyzed for repeat for publishing
terpenes original solvents
microbiological mycotoxins metals or
pesticides the simple will then the
laboratory will take you or something
your assembly and then break it out into
the smaller samples which means that's
even more critical as to why your
samples have to be representative of
what's growing in the batch that way the
subsampling that happens in laboratory
again continues to represent what's
actually happening within your product
or your back and that's our entire talk
for today so we're looking forward to
thank you John for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left of
your presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
your screen and click on the send button
well answer as many of your questions as
we have time for how much sample should
I collect the suitable amount depends on
the state and the laboratories that
you're working with I really encourage
people to understand what other state
requirements are and their laboratory
requirements are the reason we do that
is that many states are starting to set
minimum sample requirements such as
Colorado and the laboratories each have
their own different sample amounts that
they require for the different analysis
we also encourage people to collect
enough sample for more than one analysis
for two or three analyses depending on
what the analysis is this allows that
there is no symbol at the laboratory you
can go ahead and give a reanalysis if
it's necessary whether something happens
at the laboratory or the results come
back and you need a reanalysis then that
laboratory can either perform the
analysis or send that to a separate
facility interstate allows that for
reanalysis so overall we encourage
people to understand a word their state
regulatory requirements are they don't
work with their laboratories understand
how much sample is actually required for
tests that will help you narrow down
what you much simple to send and that
make sure you're not sending too much
but also sending you
here's something enough to make sure
you've got enough insurance that gets
your sample analyses so it has to be
reanalyzed done in a timely manner so I
can move forward getting that product
thank you the next one is do I need a
standard operating procedure and SOP for
sampling we would encourage everyone to
have some B's for a sampling because
that is necessary to make sure that your
sampling is consistent that everybody's
doing the same thing within your
facility within your company for a
sampling company or a laboratory or pure
facility itself that and then either way
you go from person to person to person
that sampling is being done in a
consistent manner that also ensures that
the state when they start looking at
regulatory information know the death
simply is being done in a consistent
manner as well it makes the data
meaningful that when they're looking at
things for public health concerns but it
also makes sure that you get a
consistent product back from your
laboratory a consistent product
background laboratory is consistent data
that gives you accurate accountable
information for your product and that's
really what you're looking for for your
labeling purposes and whether you
release product or not the next one is
should I change love's between each
batch oh absolutely change clothes
between these pads change gloves between
each batch clean your equipment between
each batch and make sure everything is
sanitary from batch to batch use though
we use cross-contamination rather be
microbial cross-contamination or will
there be chemical cross-contamination
for pesticides or other other
cannabinoids so we really encourage
everybody to change your gloves and
clean your good night between batches
should I clean the sampling equipment
between each batch absolutely yes please
your next one is if I buy and
concentrate do I have to test the
concentrate before I use it
in making a product that question is
from a business aspect I would say yes
you'd always want to know what your
product is coming in to the to your
process you know what the concentration
of cannabinoids are you can run either
rely on the people from giving you that
information
manufacture the concentrates or you can
do it your own testing we encourage you
to do your own testing until you to make
sure that you're a real good comfortable
relationship with that with that
manufacture he also depends on what the
requirements are for the state in some
states they do require tests in between
any time a product is is changes hands
so if you're buying a concentrate for
manufacturing purposes the state may
require testing before you get it
whether that's going into whether it's a
final product or not it doesn't matter
the state wants to know between the two
between the two parties that there's
testing done before coming in so we
encourage from a business perspective
yes that you know what's coming in but
from a regulatory perspective that you
understand that as well
okay so it's really just in this water
well thank you and we have time for one
more question if I'm making concentrate
do I have to test the concentrate before
I use it in making a product again we
would recommend that you do so it is not
recommended that you know you go without
it the type of testing that you would
want to do would be to understand what's
going on with that concentrate perhaps
potency testing and then do
microbiological and bonesy testing at
the end to make sure that your the
products that you're producing don't
contain microbial contamination but
understand they understand in the kanata
boys level going into your product
manufacturing is important so that you
know your dosage is correct in your
recipe in your formulations are covered
well I would like to once again thank
Shon Kastner from his presentation I
would also like to thank lab roots for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through June 29th 2018 you will receive
an email from lab roots letting you know
when this webcast is available for
replay please show that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon bye